ey crashes have been an issue in the Las
Vegas Valley for a long time one couple
says they're lucky to be alive after
they say their car was hit at nearly 100
miles per hour police City other driver
was impaired Sasha Loftus has our top
story tonight
[Music]
I couldn't move
um
all I thought was my kid
out turned upside down in a matter of
minutes as soon as I seen him going down
that Hill I kind of figured something
bad was gonna happen like I felt it
yasena Lopez and Anthony Figueroa say
their entire life changed a few weeks
ago when their car was hit at a red
light in North Las Vegas something that
horrendous you're not gonna be able to
know how to react police say the other
driver Isaiah Joseph armenta showed
signs of impairment driving nearly 100
miles per hour when the crash happened
and Anthony and yasena say it's nothing
short of a miracle that they walked away
with their lives I honestly think that
you know
Angels were there because I seen the car
and
I seen myself this is the intersection
where they were hurt Cheyenne and Civic
Center in North Las Vegas this has also
been the site of many deadly crashes
over the years many also involving
impairment that's why the couple tells
me they're grateful but also frustrated
I was so mad when I heard that he was
intoxicated and on a substance because
like how can you get behind a wheel
and be so selfish and they hope their
story can encourage others to think
twice before taking a risk now it
doesn't only affect your life it affects
other people's life just like us social
Loftus 8 news now yasina broke part of
her back her wrists several ribs and a
couple of toes Anthony had to be cut out
of the car later had surgery on his leg
if you would like to help them get back
on their feet we have a link to their
GoFundMe on our website